[Music]
in China verse NBA news submitted by
damn commies she said it she said it
calms Kong protesters slam LeBron James
for his comments about China and free
speech is that what he said what a
LeBron say he said China first I got to
tell you what daryl morey said which is
a Houston Rockets general manager he
tweeted out in a sense deleted tweet
this fight for freedom stand with Hong
Kong and so far as I know that's what
really sparked the whole NBA drama and
so recently LeBron James what's the
whole NBA drama Oh with China remember
we talked about it with Steve and the
whole night I wasn't here what happened
so for people who are just tuning in now
and you've never seen this before there
is a strange protest first subscribe you
done
okay now there's a huge protest going on
in Hong Kong because so Hong Kong has
this separate but a separate government
from China because they used to be a
British colony and then Great Britain or
they gave it back to China but they were
still under you know the same laws and
rules that Great Britain had and then
they said it would be a separate but but
one nation right so they have their own
passport there they yeah they run with
their own laws and stuff like that and I
think they were supposed to go back in
like 20 I'm gonna throw this number out
40 or some share 20 30 1997 and again 20
years right acclimate yeah so that
that's when they were supposed to go
back recently it all started when a
couple from Hong Kong went to Taiwan and
I think a boyfriend killed his
girlfriend in
taijuan came back to Hong Kong but what
ended up happening was the Hong Kong
cops couldn't prosecute because it was
done in Taiwan which is considered still
China and there's just all these legal
weird things right so a bill came to
play and it was like time to figure out
if people can be extradited from a crime
and then so that they could prosecute
them on Chinese soil and all these
things and from that there were so many
like things that because it was it was
like anyone could be accused for a crime
I got this part I just didn't get the
NBA part okay so now fast-forward that's
where that's where it started to that's
where all the protests there was a line
that was drawn it's like either are for
Hong Kong or you're for China and that's
when Houston Rockets general manager
decided well I'm for Hong Kong and that
just really created like a domino effect
for all of MBA
where was the domino effect Nike pulled
their spot the sponsorship of the prison
rockets team yeah cuz Nike I guess has a
lot of business factories and a lot of
Chinese people buy shoes and things like
that so they're just like well we can't
have you say that so they pulled the
sponsorship from the Houston Rockets
also just add because hey where'd you
come from
oh right over there basically with the
NBA honk China is a huge like as a
nation is a huge proponent for the NBA
as a business and the Houston Rockets
because they can't they draft a yeah
Maine back in a day like 10 years ago
Houston Rockets is China's favorite team
and so for a Houston Rockets general
manager to come in and go we're Pro Hong
Kong big big that makes sense but ok so
if you're for Hong Kong does that mean
you're for Hong Kong made like being a
city-state continue to be a city staff
earth independent or yeah and if you're
for China then it's to like democracy
versus
exactly so like because democracy well
yeah I mean yeah it's I mean car China
is a one-party state right
it's ran by the Chinese Communist Party
and then Hong Kong it's like America
where there's multiple different parties
and it's more Western in the way that
they yeah so the protests are protesters
who are fighting for independence
yes yeah but now they've treated with
like so much like mistreatment and stuff
and and police brutality about foreign
police they're like Chinese police or no
it's Hong Kong police but they're
pressured from the Chinese government
because ultimately Hong Kong is a part
of China now so yeah they're like the
mayor and everyone they're getting
pressure from you know big government
and they're telling them you got to do
this you got to do that so you know
there's just a lot of crazy [ __ ] that
went down like they hired the mob to go
out and beat protesters they have that's
so crazy yeah now LeBron James he said
this during a press conference thingy in
the speech yes we argue that freedom of
speech about what at times there are
ramifications for the negative that
can't happen when you're not thinking
about others only you only think about
yourself so I don't believe I'm gonna
get to a word of word or sentence fueled
with Harold with Darryl Morin but I
believe he wasn't educated on on the
situation at hand and any spoke and
so many people could have been harmed
not only financially but physically Oh
mainly financially all babies so just be
careful what we would tweet let me say
what we do yeah in the negative things
that he's talking about is all financial
when he's saying there might be negative
things that can happen from your freedom
of speech it's all talking about I'm
afraid that I'm losing money and all of
us are gonna lose money losing my
sponsors angry in China and and they
were losing money because they're all
doing this preseason thing right now in
the for the NBA and they're all playing
in China I've been literally just got
our plane in China and as they just got
wined and dined by them all negativity
repercussions exactly and a lot of them
are flying out there not just for the
pieces and games but to do appearances
and stuff like that
and all their appearances and a lot of
the sponsorships are being canceled as
they arrived yeah so then the reason why
so many people are upset with LeBron
James now after making that comment is
because people are like how hypocrite of
you because he was very vocal with the
whole black lives matter movement and
like so yeah this is his tweet that he
tweeted out last year and people are
throwing the section of the base because
it says injustice anywhere is a threat
to justice everywhere our lives begin to
end the day we become silent about
things that matter he tweeted that out
and then now he's saying like just be
quiet
yeah even though there's an injustice
somewhere exact cause when it hurts his
own bank account that's when people go
Shh we don't have to be so political
like Democrats so a Hong Kong is pissed
rightfully so and so bring this there on
jumbo they're burning his jersey [ __ ]
your basketball man but remember we're
protesting against him
remember when that lady told him they
showed up at your boy Hong Kong we got
remember that was a big thing a news
reporter just said like Oh
basketball players shoot shut up and
dribble exactly and he was like uh yeah
so then now he's like he wants to shut
up and res Thank You Maury stand with
Hong Kong holding it's funny that he's
even saying I don't think he's educated
about this whole situation cuz it's like
you sound uneducated man yeah so that's
the drama what's he saying I'm educated
and I think that Hong Kong people should
be prosecuted in China that's true I
think China pays the good but I think if
I was a basketball player and then I I
mean like what kind of sucks to is you
always have these reporters that are
looking for these sound bites and it'd
be juicy and controversial so they're
probably asked him hey what do you think
LeBron he's just finished playing
basketball and then cuz I hear so many
fighters all the time where they're like
can he just asked me about my fight and
stop asking me about all this other
[ __ ] but since he is provocative
girls right now and he's the he's like a
super superstar that they have to ask
him about all these other things
super superstar he's gotten trained on
PR before he didn't have to say like I
think he's uneducated about that like he
would have been like out of there like
honestly
that's some [ __ ] yellow lives matter
[ __ ] I don't know anything about that
don't [ __ ] him even yeah yeah that would
have been a talk to me about [ __ ]
basketball but then I guess like the
same person's gonna be like injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
everywhere he should have just been like
I'm sorry I'm not you know I shouldn't
be answering this I don't know enough
information to body but I'm definitely
gonna look into it out of like someone
possibly a basketball well he ended up
like swerving the conversation in
another interview thing after the
backlash from that first thing that you
did yeah and then he was just like he
pretty much
maneuvered the conversation would be
like well I'm really focused on like the
inner-city kids smart hey I think that
he is actually working towards so yeah I
think now he's just like damn I [ __ ]
yeah it's difficult because when even
with me and I'm obviously nowhere near
LeBron James yet people do expect me to
have a stance on so many different
issues especially when I do take a
stance with like empowering women Pam
really I you know talk about my history
with domestic violence and like certain
things about my personality people
expect me to speak on every issue
related to that but you really do have
to have your one laser focus and it's
hard to speak on everything because
you're not you can't be educated on
every one or two things and you can like
care about the other things but like you
where you really put your energy you can
only really help like those things that
you're passionate about to you because
there's so many [ __ ] up things and
people will still try to cancel you
though because totally on something
specific
how come that never happens to me cuz
you're not a lady true Emmitt nobody
expects me to stand take a stand on
anything because you haven't taken a
stand on anything maybe political that's
true nevermind I I rescind
I mean I think immediately reason I
think ever since I had that decision to
focus on this one thing because I used
to talk a little bit about politics and
you know I would do you ever tell people
to shut the [ __ ] up cuz I dunno I try to
be diplomatic but that's where you know
like I got cancelled one time and I was
like oh yeah because let me tell you I
can't get cancelled if I'm not on the
keyboard you know what I'm saying
I got canceled because I'm a this is
geese honk well I don't know how I made
a shirt that said feminine savage and
that was offensive to indigenous people
that word but that's such a bro word too
I know and that's a wonderful [ __ ]
savage she's a [ __ ] savvy and and I
was so the whole Native community was
like I don't want to lift with her
anymore no I'm a savage my not the whole
but there are a few it was only the
Cherokee
because a few it like people who were
indigenous from indigenous ancestry
reached out to me and explained to me a
few things but I got more criticism from
people who weren't a part of that
community why people are buried I
understand
bad for white people I don't know why
people be fighting each other about
racism and [ __ ] the n-word for Native
Americans
I mean someone tried to make that
comparison and they it was a black woman
who's made that comparison and I said I
gotta stop talking to you right now
because you can't compare savage to the
n-word I'm just like sorry that's those
aren't the saying the word savage you're
not saying the n-word if they're that's
and that's those conversations I was
engaging in them and now I just like
that's all
if I get cancelled like that's what I'm
saying is you're kind that you actually
engage in the conversation because like
I would just humiliate them or not deal
with them for for being crazy like I
don't know if they go public political
stance um not really but I do remember
in the past I tried to you know I've
always tried to like incorporate I'm a
white lady with like a couple of
businesses so I always tried to make
sure that there was some representation
in my companies and like but what if
they suck though go well it's like why
do I have to hair like hire some people
because of their race they could [ __ ]
suck and I wouldn't want them I want to
hire people that I like that are you
don't find people of different races
that are dull and then you have like
different perspectives in your company I
think those yeah but I got to go out of
my way I just want to go around my
proximity good diversity in your company
by accident but this I think I wanted it
all Asian but then you got step it up I
was trying to be exclusive no I was
trying to be racist but you know what
happened is like you're dated Mexicans
[Music]
[Music]